In the '18 100 women were
prohibited from shopping
NARRATOR: That's right.
In the middle of
the Victorian era,
a woman's role in
public life was limited.
Their duties were
confined to the home,
turning flour into bread, fabric
into clothing, empty homes
into loving places for
their husbands to return to.
Men dominated
America's growing city
centers, where they
worked and discussed
politics, business, money--
things women weren't even
supposed to think about.
Many upper- and
middle-class women
had servants or
door-to-door salesmen
bring the goods they needed
directly to their homes.
An unchaperoned woman on
the city streets was taboo.
Women weren't even allowed
to shop on their own.
And public bathrooms
at the time?
For men only.
But that would all change
with industrialization.
Consumer goods were
being churned out
at an increasingly rapid pace.
Clothing, furniture, flatware--
everything a home could need.
And sellers knew there was
demand to match the supply,
so they set out to create a
place where it was socially
acceptable for women to
shop and, more importantly,
spend time outside of
the house on their own.
Behold, the department store.
Victorian women
finally felt empowered
to go out in public
alone, to a place where
their needs were placed first.
Department stores were somewhere
to feel at ease, to socialize,
relax, and enjoy
modern amenities that
had long been reserved for men.
To create a more
welcoming environment,
they were staffed almost
entirely by other women
and featured dining rooms,
nurseries, beauty parlors--
and, yes-- even bathrooms.
And the stores themselves
were far from small.
Most took up at least
an entire city block.
By 1893, Marshall
Field's store in Chicago
contained 100 different
departments serviced by 23
elevators and 3,000 employees.
And as the shopping experience
evolved, so did social norms.
Unaccompanied women on the city
streets became commonplace,
and female foot traffic
came to determine the value
of commercial real estate.
Today, we can't imagine a world
where women aren't allowed
to shop, even though
many of us are more
than happy to do it from home.